-It is so great to see you.
-Thanks. You too.
-They love you.
We love you.
-Thanks. Thanks.
-We were talking backstage about
your little baby, your son.
One and a half.
[ Audience awws ]
[ Applause ]
What a doll.
-I love him so much.
-How is fatherhood?
How is parenthood?
-Do you want TV version
or real life?
-I don't want the Internet
talking but tell me real life.
Tell me both.
-Here's the honest truth.
I love my son, gosh,
more than life itself.
He's the best thing
in the world.
And I never really understood
love until my baby was born.
[ Audience awws ]
However, to balance it out,
no one warns you that you really
are just going to become nuts.
It's so hard. It's so hard.
I love him so much but I'm so
excited for bedtime every day.
But then as soon as I put him
into bed, I watch the monitor
thinking, "I miss him so much."
I miss him so much.
-You have the monitor?
-Yeah.
-You're at that phase.
-Yeah. I love him.
I just need him to sleep
every now and then.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a lot of work.
-I need a break.
I'm almost 40. I can't --
[ Woman gasps ]
Wow, I love the gasp.
[ Laughter ]
-How is the baby's style?
-He's a baby!
-I know. I'm sorry. I know.
But you, I'm assuming --
-Okay. You've got two, right?
-Yes.
-You know this all too well.
When they're a toddler,
they're vomiting all the time.
They're pooping all the time.
There's blowouts.
Like, they're muddy.
-Blowouts.
[ Laughter ]
-There are constant blowouts.
And so I don't put him
in a nice outfit.
Like people, very kind people,
entertainers will send, like,
designer things
as a "Oh, my gosh,
I can't believe you're a parent.
Here you are.
Here's something fancy
for your child."
-No, I can't believe that. I go,
"You've clearly never had a
child."
-Yeah, I'm never putting him in
that.
Thank you for wasting
your money.
That's never going on my child.
-No, ever.
The baby just spits up.
-He's in cheapo onesies.
-Onesies, that's all you need.
-That's it.
And also I get a size too small
so he looks
really fat and sausaged.
[ Laughter ]
Aww! Aww!
-Nothing better than that.
-It's so cute.
I mean, he can't move,
but I, like, don't care.
"You look great.
You look great, kid."
-That's so funny.
-Yeah, so nice.
-You and your husband just
celebrated 15 years?
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.
Dream. Love it.
-Isn't that wild? 15 years.
-It flew by. I can't believe
it's been 15 years.
I still feel 17.
I can't believe I've been with
him since I was 2. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-When you walk around --
When Tan France walks around
New York City, do people just
freak out and go like,
"Love you, dude"?
-It's so nice. Okay.
Here's the thing.
You're all so nice in New York.
It's lovely.
So, I live in Salt Lake City,
Utah. Hi.
I live in Salt Lake City, Utah,
and it's different.
When I'm in other places, people
will just give you a hug,
and they want to say hello, and
they're really sweet about it.
When I'm in New York, you guys
do something really weird here.
You're too cool for school,
which is sometimes very nice.
And so, they'll kind of --
There's this thing where they'll
kind of look over, and they'll
smile, and they'll move
their hair as they're walking
towards you.
So it's kind of like they're
flirting with you.
I'm like, "Are you DTF or do you
know me from TV?"
[ Laughter ]
Legit today, there was
this woman walking --
older lady, senior lady
walking towards me.
And I'm like, "Grandma wants to
[bleep]."
[ Laughter ]
And then, my husband
reminded me --
I know you're not allowed to
swear. I'm sorry.
-No, we'll cut that out.
We'll cut that right out, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But then, yeah, my husband
reminded me,
no, she's not flirting with you.
She probably just knows you
from TV.
-Yeah, of course.
Everyone loves you, though.
-But they don't say hi.
They just do the flirty thing.
I'm like, "Just talk to me,
man."
-It's New York. Yeah, you got to
be cool, man.
"Next in Fashion." It's a
fantastic show on Netflix.
It comes out tomorrow.
Gigi Hadid is your cohost.
And she's one of my faves.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-She's the best.
-She's A-plus.
She's A-plus-plus.
-I love her.
-And I love how comfortable
you guys are with each other
and just riff off each other.
And she's so funny. And she gets
to be funny on this show.
And she was telling me she met
you because she was depressed
and she just loves "Queer Eye"
so much.
And she ended up FaceTiming you
and invited you
over to her house.
And you came over to her house.
-Yeah. It was lovely.
So, not necessarily depressed.
She was just having a bad day.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry. I'm embellishing.
I'm embellishing.
-She was having a rough few
days, and she'd been --
-Wait. You said a bad day.
Now it's getting worse.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
She had a shocking five years.
And there I was, savior --
-On a horse.
-Yes.
That's what this lady needs,
a knight in shining armor.
And so, no, "Queer Eye"
just been out
for like maybe three weeks,
four weeks.
And she had been binge-watching
"Queer Eye."
And she felt like she was
my best friend
and I was her best friend.
-Immediately.
-Yeah, as many people do when
they watch the show.
-But did you freak out?
'Cause that's Gigi Hadid.
-Yeah. So, it was Antoni's
birthday,
and she wanted to FaceTime
through a friend.
And so, I was like,
"Yeah, let's FaceTime."
And she said, "Do you want to
come over?"
And it was Antoni's -- Antoni's
my castmate on "Queer Eye."
And I turn to Antoni and I was
like, "Hey, I know I was meant
to take you out
for a birthday lunch.
But can we go to Gigi's house
instead?"
And he was like,
"Mm-hmm, let's do that. Yep."
[ Laughter ]
'Cause she was the first famous
person we were hanging out with.
And we went over to her house
and it was just --
I was in shock the whole time
thinking, "That's Gigi Hadid."
-Yes. I mean, unbelievable, on
the cover of "Vogue" magazine.
-Yeah, talking to me
like I'm a normal person.
Like, that's insane.
-You are!
Yeah, I love her.
What can we set up for this clip
to let everyone know
what "Next in Fashion" --
-"Next in Fashion"
is a wonderful show.
We're on season two.
Gigi and I host it together.
We had the time of our lives.
We are looking for
incredible designers.
We have 12 incredible designers
who, in my opinion, are
so impressive and you're going
to fall in love with them.
They have the best
personalities.
And the fashion is major.
-Yeah.
-Major.
-Yeah, okay. Good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Tan France
in "Next in Fashion."
Take a look.
-I mean, her Instagram name is
slimfix71.
-Oh, my God, I love that that's
your mum's Insta.
Should we call Mom?
FaceTime Mom?
-Oh, my God.
-Hi, Slim.
-Hi, Mama.
-How're you doing?
-Oh, we're so well.
Why did you not let her dress
herself as a kid?
-She wanted to actually dress
less.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh!
-Oh, Amari.
-Do you love what she wears now?
-Ehh.
-Oh!
-Wow!
-My mom is out here just telling
all my business.
-Only moms.
Only moms can do that.
-You are going to love
these people.
They're amazing.
I do want to say one thing
about it, though.
Don't expect to see
a little black dress.
We're not about it. Don't.
Not interested.
-Too simple.
-Yeah, we're not looking for
something you can buy today
anywhere in any store.
We're looking to be inspired by
something new,
fresh, interesting.
Even if you hate it,
that's fine.
We just want you to think
about it.
-Let's think about it and be
the "Next in Fashion."
I get it. It begins streaming
tomorrow on Netflix.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Tan France, once again.